ANKIT JAIN: Good morning,
everyone.
Morning.
So great to see so many of you
here so early on day three of
Google I/O. Last night I wasn't
sure if I was going to
make it this early.
My name is Ankit Jain and
I lead [INAUDIBLE]
Search & Discovery
for Google Play.
And I'm extremely excited to
be here and share this
material with you today.
As most of you know, we've never
discussed our search or
discovery engines publicly
before today.
But before I get started, I
wanted to get to know you guys
a little better.
So with a raise of hands, how
many of you are making money
on Google Play today?
OK, great.
How many of you would like
to make even more
money on Google Play?
Great.
For those on YouTube, pretty
much everyone would like to
make even more money.
Let's step out of our normal
role as developers or business
owners, and for a second, let's
step into the shoes of
our users, and think
like a user when
you come to the store.
How many of you have installed
an app, just while browsing.
You were bored, you opened the
Play Store, saw something
interesting, click through
and installed it?
OK, how many of you have
installed an app because you
thought about, I need to get
something done, I need a
recipe app or I need to find
the train schedule, went
looked for it, and then
installed it.
That's a smaller portion.
And how many of you have
installed an app because a
friend of yours told you, hey,
you really have to go check
out this app.
And then you go to the Store,
look for it, and install it.
Great, so my goal today is to
talk to you about how we try
to bring these online and
offline thought processes of
how all of us install apps,
and how we try to get that
discovered on Play.
So I'm going to present you with
three high-level sets of
information.
The first one is our vision for
the new Google Play Store,
the second is some of the
details of the Search &
Discovery algorithms that we
have, and how you can take
advantage of them to get
discovered more, and, finally,
I want to leave you with five
very concrete examples of what
you can do to get discovered
more on Play.
Sounds good?
All right, great.
So let's get right into it.
A few weeks ago, we rolled out
the new version of the Google
Play Store.
It's very different than what
we had in the past.
About a year ago a group of us
stepped aside and said, if we
could re-imagine the entire
Store, the new Google Play
experience, what would
it be like?
The goal was to come up with
something that was dynamic,
very fresh, the user should be
trained and look forward to
coming back into the Store,
something that is
personalized, yet personal.
So some of you might
be thinking, Ankit,
what are you saying?
Personalized, yet personal,
what's the difference there?
Well, personalized to me is
something that is personally
relevant, related to what you've
told us in the past,
what you users have purchased;
what's personally relevant,
because it's popular in the
user's area; personally
relevant because the user has
shown interest in certain
categories or in certain
developers; or personally
relevant because your
friends are showing
interest in those things.
And then we want to take it to
the next level, we want to
make it personal by showing
you and annotating each of
these recommendations or each
of the pieces of content in
our Store with why you
should get it.
This could be a +1 by a friend,
this could be a review
by a friend, or this could be
something based on the new
Google Play Game services.
That should be and three others
are currently playing
"Puzzles and Dragons."
We should really tell the user
this is why you should get.
And our goal was to help each
and every one of you, each and
every one of our developers,
to get more engaged
installers, because at the end
of the day, that's what's
really going to move
the needle.
Those are the users that build
sustainable and great
businesses.
So our goal was threefold.
First, to help our users find
what they're looking for as
effortlessly and seamlessly,
and possible.
Second, to help Android ship
more and more beautiful apps.
And finally, to help all of you
build even more thriving
businesses on top
of our platform.
So let's get the meat
of today's talk.
Let's talk about our major
install source.
At the end of the day,
nothing can be built
unless you've got installs.
And specifically, I want
to talk about how
to get engaged installs.
So many of you reached out to me
in the past and said, hey,
I'm ranked number five, or
number 10, or number 50 on
these top lists, or on
these trending lists.
These are what I call our
browsing discovery features.
And I like to break them into
three sub-components.
The first are these top charts,
the top list, the
editor's picks, the
trending lists.
The next are the features
that we launched at
Google I/O last year.
These were the personalized
recommendations.
Some of you saw these as part
of the Google Play homepage
experience in the cluster there,
others might have seen
this on the widgets, on the
Nexus 7 and the Nexus 10 on
the home screens there.
And the last set of features
that we have for discovery
based on your context, are the
related and cross sell items.
These are the users who viewed
x, also viewed y on the
details page of all
of your app.
Also the other set which is
users who installed this app
also installed these other apps,
which is also on your
details pages.
And we'll get into details about
each of these and how we
look at them, and how the
algorithms are built.
What most developers don't think
to think about as much
is the search component.
And for the average app search
actually makes up the vast
majority of installs.
And when I think about search,
I like to break it down and
look at our query stream in
terms of two kinds of queries.
The first are the kinds of
queries that many of you
raised your hand for, which
are I had to get something
done, so I looked it up; I
needed to look up a recipe; I
wanted to find restaurant
reviews in a city that I'm in;
I want to find multiplayer
games or free
games, or RPG games--
the kind of categorical
queries.
You know the general idea of
what you want or what you want
to do, and then you search
to find the right
app to fulfill that.
The second kind of query is
when you know exactly what
you're looking for.
This is when a friend has told
you about an app, or if you've
heard about it through
marketing.
Navigational queries, hey, I
want to get hotel tonight; I
want to get "Beautylish," or I
want to get "Angry Birds,"
which is not necessarily a
single app, it could be a set
of apps, but you know which
direction you want to look in.
That's navigational queries.
And just to show you how
important search is, in any
given day 12% of our active
users come back to the Store
and search at least
once for apps.
In any given week, half of our
users come to our Store and
search for apps.
And even given the number of
apps we have in any given
month, there's over six million
unique phrases that
are being searched for.
So really thinking about search
is important, as you
try to figure out how to
get discovered on Play.
So just to put what we've talked
about, we've talked
about our vision for Google
Play, and how our goal is to
present each user with a
personalized play made
personal; how Search and
Browse are the two main
sources of installs in the
Store; and finally, a lot of
this happens because our goal
is to bring the rest
of Google to Play.
That was the transition from
Android Market into Google
Play, it was to integrate all
of our systems together and
make Google Play a very smart
Store, make it your store.
So now that we've talked about
it, let's step back and think
about how we think of our Search
& Discovery systems.
When we build our search engines
and our discovery
engines, we have two options--
either we can spend a lot of
time trying to detect the apps
that are bad or spammy, or
simply annoying, or we can spend
a lot of time trying to
figure out which
apps are good.
And we spend a lot more time
focusing on what's good,
because if we can promote the
apps that are not just good
from what we can tell, based
on your APK, based on your
metadata, based on what users
are telling us about each of
the apps, then other users are
also going to find these
delightful experiences.
And so this part of the talk is
going to be talking about
how you can compliment your app
with good app metadata.
So the most important
piece of your app
metadata is your title.
It's important to be creative,
but it's just as important, if
not more important, to
been very clear.
So this example up on screen
is about an app named
"Beautylish." As you can see,
most of you might not have
heard of it, some of you might
have heard of it, but right
after you see the title, you
know this app is about makeup
and beauty tips.
So what this title helps you do
is it helps the developer
reinforce, not just their
branding, but also what their
app is about.
So as you see this more and
more often, either in the
Store, or even once you have it
installed in your list of
apps on your home screen, it's
very clear that "Beautylish"
is the app I go to for makeup
and beauty tips.
So I highly recommend thinking
about the name of your app.
It also helps a lot for SEO.
When someone looks up "beauty
tips" or "makeup tips", these
guys are at the top of that
list, just because everyone
associates the two of those
terms together.
The next important part of
your details page in your
metadata is your description.
You can write as long a
description as you want, but I
always say, get the main
message out first.
"Star Chart" does a
great job here.
Their first sentence says that
you can now have a virtual
planetarium in your pocket.
Again, if you've never used
this app, you already know
what it's about.
After that, you can go on
describe it in more detail,
list the awards you have, and
just have your sales and
marketing pitches for users.
But right up front, make
sure your user knows
what your app is about.
And on a smaller phone, that's
the part that's above the
fold, so you want to make sure
on that first screen itself
it's extremely clear what your
goal is-- what utility you
provide or what entertainment
value or whatever the goal of
your app is-- what
it provides.
Now, that also again helps
a lot with getting found.
This app is extremely optimized
for star charts,
star maps, virtual planetariums,
so the beginning
of descriptions are extremely
important, both from a user's
perspective, and also from our
search engine's perspective.
The next couple of slides I'm
going to talk about how you
can use your app details page
to mimic the real user
experience.
It's important that you set the
expectations of your user
to be very realistic to really
be what your app
is going to be like.
The first place to do this
is in your screenshots.
In our developer console, we let
you upload screenshots for
tablets, for phones, and really
show the user what it's
going to be like once
you install the app.
Now, if you don't do this, and
your app experience is
actually very different from
your screenshots, it can have
a very negative effect on
all of your systems.
Why?
Because, well, the user loves
what they see in your details
page, they install your app,
they open the app, and then
they see something
very different.
What are they going to do?
Well, most users will
uninstall the app.
Some of those users will go back
to the Store and give you
a low rating, maybe even write
you a negative review.
And that negative feedback cycle
is going to hurt you
more than help you.
And so really thinking about
how do you present the user
with, setting the right
expectation and then
delivering on it.
That's the message here.
We're looking for apps that do
deliver on their promises.
Video previews are the next
level of screenshots.
With a short video you're able
to show the user really what
it's like to play
with your app.
And developers have told us
that uploading a video can
really help gain
user adoption.
And users in a lot of studies
have told us that video
previews are amongst the most
convincing features of an app
details page.
Again, the whole goal here
is to tell your user
what your app does.
If you can convince them and
make sure and communicate what
your app promises and then
deliver on it, you're going to
delight them, and they're going
to recommend you to
other users as well.
So I talked about reviews and
ratings in terms of the
feedback loop.
And this is a key part of our
Search & Discovery experience.
Now, the first piece of this
comes because people come back
and review your app, whether
it's good or bad.
The second piece is we really
try to order our reviews and
ratings in an order that is
relevant to the user.
So you're going to see reviews
that are on the same device as
the current user, in the same
country as the current user,
and as time goes on, people that
are in a user's circle or
people that the users trust are
going to come at the top
of these reviews.
So investing in making sure that
your users are reviewing
and rating your apps will be
key going forward, because
that's a very strong signal
for us at Google Play.
So I'm going to step back and
tell you a story about a
developer, a developer in India
that I was talking to a
few weeks ago.
And his goal was to target
the rural population.
As you can see on the graph
on the right, about 75% of
India's population lives
in rural cities.
But his goal was to target the
audience that had low- to
mid-end phones, and was on
slow to 2G networks.
So he had really optimized his
app to give a delightful
experience for these users.
But then he reached out to me
and said, Ankit, when I look
at my reviews, I have
this polarized view.
There's a whole bunch of stars
with people saying I could
never have imagined technology
would change
my world this way.
And also a lot of one stars,
with people saying, complete
crap, I can't believe I
downloaded this, uninstalling
it right now.
And he was perplexed, he wasn't
sure what was going on.
And we dug a little deeper.
And one of the things we
noticed was that he was
getting a lot of positive
reaction from the people in
rural areas, his target
audience.
And he was getting a lot of
negative reviews from the
people on the 4G networks, on
the top-of-the-line devices
because his app just was
not designed for them.
His goal was not to go
after that market.
And so the thing that he ended
up doing was he went to the
developer console and targeted
his app to the countries and
carriers where his target
audience really was.
And since then, he's already
seen an uptick in his average
reading and his reviews,
and hopefully that
continues over time.
But my message here to you
is think about who
you're trying to target.
For most apps, you don't have
to worry about this, you can
let your app get to everybody.
But if your app is targeted at
a specific set of the target
audience, make sure those are
the people helping you get
even more adoption.
You don't want people not in
your target audience polluting
your reviewer rating.
So we've talked about creating
a very creative, yet clear
message to your title and
description, to mimic your
real world experience through
your images, your screenshots
and your video previews; and,
finally, really about
understanding your audience.
This is what's going to
help you optimize
your app details page.
So let's see how this
manifests itself.
At the end of the day, there's
the top charts and the search
engines, what are the things
that we look for?
How, once you do all of these
great things in your app
details page, how does
it feedback?
And no search or discovery
system would be complete
without really taking into
account the statistics that
we're constantly collecting.
So the first piece of this, as
most of you probably already
figured out, are the installs.
Of course, we care about how
many installs each app has.
The more you have, the higher up
in the rankings you'll go.
We also care about how many
uninstalls you have, because
that's a metric for us to know
whether users are having a
good or a bad experience.
Now, some of you are game
developers out there, and you
might say, hey, my game overall
takes 1 gig of memory,
or 2 gigs of memory on
a person's device.
So after they're done playing
my game, of course, they're
going to uninstall my app,
because they want to
play the next game.
They've already won every
level there is.
Why are you going to hurt me?
And that's why we have
the third statistic,
which is long installs.
If a person plays through or
uses an app for a long period
of time, we don't want
to penalize it.
Our goal is really to detect the
behavior which is, hey, I
installed the app, I really
did not have a good
experience, so I'm installing
it right away.
So the long install
encapsulates that
phenomenon in it.
In the coming months, one of
the things that we want to
focus on is engagement, and
really understanding, for each
of your apps, when are people
using, how are they using it,
and how is it different across
different kinds of apps.
For example, Google Now, I just
go to it when I need to
pick up my latest
boarding pass.
I'm not going to spend tens if
not tens of minutes or hours
on it, but there might be a game
where I spend an hour or
two on it, but that doesn't
mean one is
better than the other.
They're just different
kinds of functions
that they're providing.
And this is an area where having
a conversation with all
of you is great, and I really
look forward to having some of
your feedback.
So a lot of this is about
setting the stage for the
first conversation we've never
discussed this before.
If you guys have ideas,
please let us know.
I'll talk about Google Play
services, the game services,
that we launched, and how we're
going to use that for
engagement in the coming
months as well.
Here's a query that I get very
often from developers.
Hey, for some search query, I'm
number three, even though
the app ranked above mine has
fewer installs and has a lower
rating than me.
I'm sure many of you have
thought about this as well .
Now, on the previous slide
I talked about
the uninstall rate.
Not only do we look at the
number of people that are
uninstalling your app compared
to the number of people
installing it, we also have
some amount of a recent
uninstall rate as well.
The idea here is that you might
have an app that has not
been updated in a couple of
years, and now more people are
uninstalling your app
than installing it.
Or there's a newer app or your
app could be on the other side
of this, where you made an
update and now a lot of people
are really keeping your app,
that's going to help you move
up in the rankings.
We want to make sure our users
are getting the best apps as
easily as possible.
So I hope this answers
this very common
question that I get.
So the other piece of what we've
talked about a lot at
Google I/O this year is
personalization across all of
our products at Google,
and Google plays no
exception to this.
We're constantly slicing and
dicing all of the data that
we're collecting in order to
personalize and improve each
user's experience.
I'll give you a couple
of examples.
The query "Yahoo" in the US
leads to people installing the
Yahoo app or the
Yahoo Mail app.
In Japan, however, people are
installing the Yahoo Japan
app, and over time our systems
learned this and figured out,
hey, in Japan, show Yahoo Japan
as number one, in the US
show Yahoo and Yahoo Mail
as number one and two.
Similarly, on tablets, people
tend to install different apps
than they do on mobile
devices.
So, again, using the feedback
loops of what people are
searching for, what they're
clicking on, and what they're
enjoying installing, we're
able to really tailor the
search experience and the search
results per device
type, per locale, and across
a whole bunch of different
dimensions.
About a year ago, in addition
to having the search
suggestions as you type, we
added the ability to have
navigational search
suggestions.
These are suggestions that
Google believes are the right
one for a user.
So as this user is typing in
SUB, most users tend to
actually go straight to "Subway
Surfers," so we
allowed the user to do
that right from the
search suggest box.
If you click on that
navigational suggestion, you
won't go to a search
results page.
You'll go straight to the
app's details page.
It even shows you the icon of
the app that it's going to
take you straight to.
Now, if a user wants to find the
tips or the strategies, or
other apps that are around
"Subway Surfers," they can
still complete their query and
look at the app details page.
Again, the theme here is that
we're trying to make it easier
for users to get
what they want.
Let's switch gears
a little bit.
And I'll let you look at this
for a couple of seconds,
there's a lot of
data up there.
So a lot of you always have
asked the question, how are
your top lists generated?
When are they generated?
And what's the rationale
behind them?
Now, not like any search or
discovery system, we're
constantly tuning our systems.
And this is a snapshot of what
it looks like recently.
There's a basic quality barrier
that's there, there
are some review and rating
metrics that we take into
account, but at a high level, we
create top lists daily per
country, per category, and
even for device type.
You guys saw some of the design
for tablet top list
that were launched
earlier at I/O.
And our top paid free and
grossing list are really
targeting first-time users to
Google Play, or people that
just got a new device, because
they're looking for the basic
apps that they need to
load up in order to
get their stuff done.
What's most popular
on Google Play?
The top new paid and the top new
list are targeting users
who have the basic apps and
say, hey, what's new right
now, what's new and popular?
And for that reason we limit it
to the apps that have been
published in the last 30 days.
And this is very important,
because many app developers
launch an app in a single
country and then over time
roll it out to a bunch
of countries.
So I get a question a lot of
times saying, hey, I just
launched in Italy last week,
and it's going gangbusters.
We're just getting more installs
than we ever have,
how come we're not in the
top and new free or
top new paid list?
Well, the reason is your
original launch might have
been six months ago, and so
you're not qualified to be in
the top new list of even new
countries that you launch in.
It's a global published
date that we look at.
So also think about your global
roll-out strategy.
If being in the top new list is
part of your strategy, that
30-day window is extremely
important.
And the metrics across these
are different, for the
grossing we look at the
revenues, for the others look
at installs over the
last several days.
The next list that I want to
talk about is our trending
list, and this is one that has
had no clarity about it ever.
Internally, we like to call it
our Movers & Shakers list.
Our goal here is to present the
user with a system that
can give them what's really
hot right now.
Amongst all the apps on Google
Play, what are the apps that a
lot of users, more than we
predict, are being installed?
So for every app we have a
predicted growth rate.
This predicted growth rate takes
into consideration where
in your app life cycle
you are, and how many
installs you have.
And then, if a given app
performs significantly better,
if it starts getting installs
much faster than what we
predict, it makes it
into this movers &
shakers, or trending list.
So when the soccer World Cup was
going on a couple of years
ago, the FIFA app was at
the top of this list.
Last year when the unfortunate
tsunami hit Japan, many
radiation tracking apps were
on the top of this list.
And any app can be part
of this list.
And we're looking at a 30-day
window to figure out really
what's hot right now.
I mentioned the Related
and Cross Sell
features that we have.
These are on every app's
details page.
They are the people who viewed
this, also viewed these other
apps, and the users who
installed this app, also
installed these other apps.
Let's go through
a few examples.
The first one's Bank
of America, a user
looking to do banking.
When they're considering a
banking app, they might
consider other banking apps-
Paypal or Wells Fargo, but
once they've decided to get
the Bank of America app,
they're more likely to install
a complementary app, not a
supplementary app.
So here you see them installing
a trading app, such
as "Merill Edge," or another app
by the same developer the
BOFA Health app.
In the middle is an example of a
user looking to get a Bible.
Users looking to get a Bible
might consider the various
options, but once they get the
Bible, they'll get other
religious apps, not other
Bible apps, so it's
complementary to what they've
already gotten.
The third example is a widget
that helps users show the time
on their home screen.
They might consider "Digiclock"
or "Dashclock" but
once they instal the "Dashclock"
widget, they've
bought into that style, that
ecosystem, so then they're
more likely to install other
widgets or other add-ons that
have the same style, to have
the unified experience on
their Android device.
Last year at Google I/O we
launched Personalized
Recommendations.
As I said, these were on the
home screen of the Google Play
homepage and they've been
performing extremely well.
And with the new launch of
Google Play, we really decided
to double down on this and
start personalizing many
different parts of our system.
So I thought it's a good
opportunity for me to tell you
what really we look for.
We have over 80 signals not
just from Google Play, but
also from the rest of Google.
But some of our major signals
include apps that are
complementary and supplementary
to apps that
users installed in the past.
We look at apps that are popular
in the user's area.
We look at apps that are being
+1'd by a user's circles.
Apps that were reviewed
by a user's circles.
We also look at apps that are
developed by some of you, if
the users are already showing
interest in your developer
account, by other apps by you.
So here are some recommendations
for three
different users.
You can see +1s by
people's friends.
You can see apps that are
similar to other things
they've bought, also apps that
are popular in their area.
So how does this manifest
itself?
So this is the homepage
that we envision.
This is going to start rolling
out to different users over
the coming months.
On the left, is my grandmother's
home page, that'
what she sees.
She grew up very close to
military quarters in India,
because my grandpa lived
in that area.
And she was very interested
in getting stuff done.
We call her the colonel
of the family.
So for her actually the tasklist
makes so much sense.
But growing up in a military
area also means that you play
a lot of cards.
She actually plays two to four
hours of card games a day.
It's ridiculous, I don't
know how she does it.
And so seeing the tablet
highlight apps for her, and
seeing the card game right
up there is really what's
relevant to her.
For me, I travel a lot, and so
on the tablet highlights
section not only do you see
Google Translate, which I
should get so that I can
communicate with people all
around the world.
But it also tells me why.
It tells me that my
friend Abinahm has
+1'd this app here.
He had a great experience, so
that helps me improve trust in
the system and get this app.
You can take this a step
further, on all four category
homepages both of these
are for me.
On the left, I live in San
Francisco, so you see the San
Francisco Giants app, you see
the Oakland Baseball app, you
see Sacramento Kings app,
on the right is
the news home page.
You see news apps and magazine
apps that are related to what
I bought in the past.
I have "Pulse" and people who
have "Pulse tend to also enjoy
"New York Times." It's amazing
to me that "Times of India"
comes on my personalized home
page, but it wouldn't on some
of yours just because my friends
tend come from that
part of the world, and they
say this is a great
app to adopt it.
How can we apply personalization
to search?
I've talked about using
location, so a user in Japan
will see different results for
Yahoo than a user in the US.
But we think categorical queries
are a place where we
can really help the user find
what they're looking for.
Imagine the user researches
for free games.
If we know that they like word
games, showing them free word
games makes a lot of sense.
If they like RPG games, showing
them those kind of
games is going to help get a
much faster acquisition rate.
For train schedules, a user in
New York should get the subway
train schedule, a user in San
Francisco should get either
the BART train schedule or
the Caltrain schedule.
It just makes sense.
And so over the coming months,
we're going to roll out more
experiments.
And, finally, to everybody,
personalization across
categorical searches.
So I've thrown a lot of
things at you so far.
So just to step back
and summarize it.
We've talked about the search
statistics, the feedback loops
that we look at in order to
improve our search and our
discovery systems.
We talked about navigational
search suggestions.
We talked about how our top
charts are generated across
each category , generated
daily and
across every country.
We talked about what trending
apps are, what it means to be
in there, and how you
can get in there.
We talked about how related
and cross sell works.
And we also talked about how
we're starting to personalize
Play and how that's going to
roll out over the coming
months, and how that really
fulfills our vision of a
personalized Play
made personal.
So I promised you, guys, I'll
leave you with five things
that you can do to improve your
discoverability on Play.
So let's get right into it, but
before we do that, I want
to tell you it's just as
important to build a good app.
To take the time to go through
those app developer guidelines
on developer.android.com and
make sure you have a good app.
You can complement that by
optimizing on the store, but
at the end of the day, nothing
substitutes a very good
experience for your app.
Two months ago we added
a list of guidelines.
The Tablet [? App ?]
Guidelines, what it means to
be designed for tablets.
And I highly recommend that you
get this design for tablet
designation.
Earlier at I/O we announced
the design for tablets top
lists on some of
our home pages.
Over time this is going to roll
across the Store, so a
tablet user really gets the best
experience possible by
showing the apps and promoting
the apps that have gone
through the trouble of making
that experience better.
So you're going to see this not
just on the top list, but
over time in search and
all of our other
discovery features as well.
The developer console helps
you with optimization tips
that they've added, and then in
the next talk by [? Ali ?]
[? Mausen ?]
[? Ricardo ?] we'll go through
this in detail-- what you can
do to really get some of
these designations.
So get the "Designed for
Tablet" designation
Number two, and this is a much
less known fact about the way
we do search ranking
at Google Play.
Today most articles that are
published on the web about
Play apps have a link at the
end that says Google Play
Store, or play link.
Actually over 99% of anchors
that we get into the Google
Play Store just have
those two phrases.
And that doesn't
help us at all.
We want to help you get
discovered even on Play.
Sure, you tell us a little bit
about your app, but if a
trusted source on the right,
for example, TechCrunch, is
telling us what your
app is about.
Even before you have any
installs, we can trust that
and start boosting you
for those terms.
So next time you're talking to
a blog writer or someone
writing an article about your
app, have them give you some
link juice.
Have them put something
interesting in those links
linking to your app
The third one is to avoid
common mistakes.
I told you there were 6 million
and more unique
phrases that are searched
for every month.
What I didn't tell you is over
half of them are misspelled.
That's amazing that half the
people are mistyping queries,
but that's just how the query
stream is on mobile today.
So as Google what we have to do
is we have to aggressively
correct for it.
We have to make sure we help
the user find what they're
looking for, even
if it's a typo.
So the one thing you can learn
from this is don't name your
app something that is a cute but
a common misspelling of a
very popular app, because
chances are a user looking for
your app will get autocorrected
into something
that you're not happy with.
The second thing I already
talked about, using the
targeting expressions on the
developer console carefully,
which countries and carriers
you're targeting depending on
your target audience.
And the third one, again, is one
that is a little subtle,
but I think it's important.
If you do have a developer URL
that is not a play.google.com
link or a code.google.com,
something that is
your home on the web.
If it exists, do make sure
you upload that in
the developer console.
Why?
Well, we crawl the web, we
index the web for our web
search, and we use a lot
of those signals in
order to help you.
If we know that you're the
kind of developer that is
about a specific subset of the
world, we will help you get
discovered when people are
looking for those terms on
Google Play.
So again, if you have a
developer URL other than
something at google.com,
do upload that.
Number four, is to make
your APK smaller.
Users tend to install smaller
apps, a lot more than they do
larger apps.
And they tend to uninstall
larger apps at a
higher rate as well.
Let's think about why.
As your phone runs
out of memory--
there's a finite amount
of memory--
users tend to go through the
list of apps they have, in
decreasing order of size, and
start uninstalling the apps
that they're using
least actively.
So the further down that list
you are, the less likely you
are to be uninstalled.
So make your APK size smaller.
In the coming months we're going
to start looking deeper
into the APK from a search &
discovery perspective as well.
We're going to look at the kind
of SDKs you're linking
with, the libraries you're
linking with to figure out
what is your app really about.
Looking at the kind of sites
that your app is connecting
with by emulating it; and try
to really figure out what is
your app about, so we can help
users find apps that will help
them do what they're
looking to do.
And the last one--
and this is something many of
you asked us for-- is to
create a second channel of
distribution, the viral channel.
There hasn't been too much of a
viral channel, and I'm going
to go through a few things that
we're going to be pushing
over the coming months.
The first one are highly
rated apps.
These are apps that your
friends, your circles, and
others that you trust have rated
highly in our Store.
So here are some apps that
are rated highly for me.
On the right you see at the
"Quora" app is rated highly by
my roommate David.
He rated it five stars.
Then "Logo Quiz." my friend
Ruthica said it's an extremely
fun game, it's so addicting,
she couldn't stop.
That's the personal touch
that we can add to
the Google Play Store.
Some of these apps have never
been on the homepage.
This is the easiest way for each
of you to get on Google
Play's homepage.
Have your users review
your apps.
Their friends will start seeing
them on their Google
Play homepage.
I've talked a lot about
+1 already.
+1 has been an integral part of
our system since we first
personalized recommendations
last year.
The reason I bring it up again
is because there's an API,
which I'm not sure why many
of you are not using.
This API is available on the
Google+ recommendations API
page and it enables you to allow
your users to +1 an app
from within your app.
So you don't have to have a
message that says go to Google
Play and +1 my app.
You don't need to have your
users leave your experience.
Keep them in your app.
We want to make it easier.
So we already have in-app
billing for you guys, there's
the in-app +1.
And in coming months we're going
to also have in-app rate
and review.
So again, we don't want your
users to leave your app.
If we can do what they need to
do from within your app,
great, and we're going to help
you do that as well.
And the last thing to create the
viral loop is to integrate
with Google Play
Games services.
At first, what you are going to
get is when someone opens
your app, they can see which of
their friends are playing,
they can find opponents--
it makes your app more
interactive.
You've got the multiplayer, you
have the leader boards--
it makes your app social.
In the longer term though, this
along with the Google
Plus Moments API, which allows
you to share specific piece of
information.
I'm currently playing this game
or I'm at level 27 of
this game will allow us in the
Store to annotate and make
things more personal.
How great would be if my
homepage said, right now
[? Shellaby ?]
is looking for an opponent for
"Riptide." That's the best way
to not only get someone to
install your app, but open it
right away.
Get you those engaged users
that you're looking for.
So that's how I recommend
integrating with the Google
Play Games services.
Again, the five things that
you should do to get
discovered more in Play.
Get the Designed for Tablets
designation.
Start getting helpful web
anchors, avoid some of the
common mistakes about
misspellings, because we have
to auto correct for them,
and targeting
your audience correctly.
Reduce the size of your APK, and
then really start closing
that viral loop.
Help your users promote
you in addition to
depending on just the store.
So we've talked a lot about
user acquisition.
I've talked about the organic
growth that you can get from
the Search & Discovery aspects
of the Google Play Store.
We've talked about the viral
aspect of Search & Discovery,
and many of you already know
about the paid aspect, which
is important to some of your
businesses as well.
I won't talk too much about
it, but what I will say is
that investing in paid user
acquisition can have a very
positive impact on organic
and viral growth as well.
And so if you can, is it is
something to think about in
the bigger picture of things.
Now user acquisition is just
the first step in creating
lifetime value for your users.
As a business owner, I always
like to think about my key
metrics and have a very
good handle on them.
And the one that I found in the
mobile space and in any
user-centric space is the
lifetime value of
every one of my users.
We talked about user
acquisition, let me briefly
mention the other two.
User retention I like to break
into two different ratios.
The first is a short-term
user retention ratio.
This is how do I initially
keep my users?
Most of the time this happens
because the users like what
you're promising them.
They install your app,
they open it.
The long-term user retention
ratio, which is very much like
the long install metric that I
talked about, is the on-going
mechanics of your app.
Or what you develop, you
delivering on your promise.
So in the example of "Scramble
With Friends," initially they
got a lot of their users because
it was very much like
the word games when
[INAUDIBLE]
grew up with, but over time
their social, their
interactive features and what
kept them growing and made it
successful.
User monetization I look at
in terms of two different
lenses-- the big picture is the
revenue for install, and
that makes sense-- it's a very
good macro metric, and its
comparable to your user
acquisition costs, your cost
per install as well.
So you can do that.
But the real picture is the
revenue per active user,
that's what you have most
control over-- the people that
are in your system, in your
game, in your app, and how can
you tune it to make
the most money.
So as you think about your
users, try and to break it
down into the key metrics
and have a very
good handle on them.
So I hope that this talk is held
to get a good idea of how
we build some of our Search
& Discovery systems.
My goal was to really start
this conversation.
I want to continue it.
And none of this would have been
possible without my team
on Google Play.
So this is my shout
out to them.
Thank you for doing all the
great stuff that you've done .
And for all of you, thank you
for being here so early.
I would like to continue
this conversation.
I'll be at office hours right
after this, so if you have any
questions, please come there.
Or you can reach out to me
on Google+ or Twitter.
And I'm happy to
continue this.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]